Luke Cage first appeared in Jessica
Jones on Netflix and then there's Sodom
in marvel hey let's give him out his own
series and have mike colter play him and
then have Netflix crash when season 1
came out and now season 2 is gonna be
available for streaming June 22nd
thrilled to have Mike Colter here on the
Rich Eisen show good to see you you
written graduations in advance of this
conversation and all your success it's
amazing what this show has become what
it is yeah you know it's like the fans
it's all about the fans the fans were
there and you know I always say it
starts to the writing the creator and if
people enjoy what we're doing we're
trying to make it better we hope you
have a better second season at first so
I'm hoping we can crash the internet
again okay sure it's gonna ensure it's
coming so what what's your team's oh man
we down on your teams well I I'm I'm a
Laker fan that's right you you know
watch watching sports I grew up in South
Carolina no major teams there Carolina
Panthers didn't come along into the 90s
and that was not good for me because at
the time I was a Cowboys fan
okay now I'm sort of taking a break on
the Cowboys but you know that's we'll
get to that later you taking a press
taking a break can I take a break man
the whole organization I gotta take a
break okay I got to take a break well
why are we taking a break well you know
I mean honestly I mean I just look I
love I love the Cowboys but when you
watch a team is frustrating because you
feel like they're they're broken from
the management down and then this whole
thing now with Jerry Jones I just feel
like they're the leadership is this not
where it should be and so I'm not gonna
put my timing okay so you're taking a
break from the Cowboys taking a break
taking a break all right so is there an
NFL team that you have turned you know I
like the owner like the Jets you know
the Jets owner man is talking talking
the kind of stuff I like to hear man
okay yeah he's a national anthem is
she's treating his men you know like men
so I I respect that you know I think um
as a matter of fact that they're head
coaches are gonna make an appearance
he's making an appearance on cage season
two so I might be a Jets fan this season
on a sec yeah Todd Bowles Todd Bowles
pops up man he's in Luke Cage yeah yeah
all right all right so know can we can
you give us a little more meat on them
well actually we dropped a little teaser
trailer he's cage is going through some
stuff and he's trying to see what what
uh what what NFL teams might be
interested in his services so Todd
Bowles plays himself
plays himself yeah cuz I know you bet
you're based in New York yeah so why not
have why not have him come up yeah so
Todd both so speaking is a lifelong New
York jet fan please tell me that Luke
Cage is gonna suit up for the
York Jets can't tell you things to me
listen to streaming out you'd either
stream it gotta leave you something to
look for yeah do we have do we have Todd
Bowles you remember that that drop for
him he lost his mind about Sam Donald do
you have that still Mike Dell - phone
gotta get that okay okay in the meantime
so alright so now you're you mike colter
now looking at the Jets yeah oops now
Lakers are you are you hoping that
LeBron joins the team you know Lakers in
rebuilding um you know I'm a Laker fan
and when they when they had the little
split back when they had to choose
between Kobe Shaq I was happy that Kobe
stayed and and we rebuilt and you know
we had a little time up but we were
always very competitive I think now we
have a couple pieces but I don't I don't
see him coming there
I think the East is where he likes to be
um whoever comes to the Lakers I will
then I will avenge you know hopefully
become be a fan of theirs okay now that
being said when Dwight came I wasn't I
wasn't hunting on board on that and they
were might Howard Dwight Howard came I
wasn't a hundred percent abortions Kobe
at all no I don't think so they're just
a fit thing and you know it's nothing to
do with him I remember being in LA and
he was he was coming in before he signed
I saw him hanging around LA and I was
like walking around the mall Simon I'm
going wandering in literally days later
it was he signed so now I'm thinking you
know you know they've been Knicks the
whole Chris Paul thing which I mean I'm
still devastated by that I feel so bad
you know Chris Paul I want him to be
healthy this season I want him to play
as long as he could play they didn't let
him hang a hook up with Kobe I'm still
still mad about that still mad about
that you know that was that was another
ring for us gonna tell you I mean talk
about how differently things could have
worked oh so differently so different
right said he goes to the Clippers now
he's on the Rockets and then he gets
injured and India and this is this the
first time that he made the Western
Conference I know I was in his entire
career I know I fell for him this time I
thought he was about to beat the
Warriors yeah I'm Vaughn to the finals
and then that dress you go to game seven
you had the drama that you had in Boston
at least that much because then you you
know at least them to be injured for two
games you could eat just but in 27
straight missed three-pointers by the
Rockets I still can't believe well I
don't think they would have done that it
he were on the floor I feel like you
know veteran leadership I think he would
have started to you know change the
change the chemistry a bit because that
didn't make any sense to me either
I mean that
you can get lulled into that because the
Golden State Warriors start going in
threes and you feel like you have to
start to match that but that being said
you got to be able to go inside out you
got to get a good look and you got to
have rhythm its rhythm shot sometimes he
knows rhythm shots Luke Cage himself
Mike Colter here on the Rich Eisen show
did you ever try sports yourself before
getting into active I play one year of
everything and it was never for me III I
played football and I'm hitting a guy in
the special teams and I hit him pretty
hard got my bell rung everybody was
cheering and I could hear your ringing
in my head and I said you know what this
doesn't make any sense I don't know I
don't know about this is the sport like
you know it doesn't feel right for me
and I said this is this is this is
probably it for me this is making me
sense hitting my head against someone as
hard as I could
know so every other sport you played
played one year everything one years
oops
had one year who was your shot how's
your game listen you know what I'm
better now than ever was then you can
relate to that Brock when he sounds like
you I'm Way better now that was then way
better now so is it possible somebody
goes and here in Los Angeles and then
you're in a pickup game or so oh we I
play pickup on up in Paul Revere high
school or is it high school or middle
school
okay I'm Brent would be some meet some
guys pick up on the weekend when I'm in
town I try to get in it's it's guys from
25 to 60 I mean we're decide they're
breaking a sweat we were playing like if
we play play Spurs basketballs like all
the Spurs yeah we're moving the ball
around with breaking a sweat nobody's
getting hurt we're not trying to take it
so what's your shot I mean my shot I got
a couple today about your game here I'm
six-three right okay in high school I
was one of the taller people there were
a couple tall guys but they forced me
into the low post game so I didn't play
a lot my face in the basket okay I
developed and back then I could do it
like a drop step dunk I was I was you'd
play low post so I had a couple shots I
had a good I got a good fadeaway okay I
got a good I got a good elbow from the
elbow shot and I got a good bank shot
but mostly I like to I like to go and
cross the lane so I like that magic shot
you remember back in 80s we cross this
Lane sure instead of hooking it I like
to come up and I go under so no matter
what you know it's coming but it's hard
to stop it because you everybody goes to
the basketball if you can palm it like
dr. J you can bring it under so that's
my move so you flash is that you do you
flash open I do you flash I do what do
you like my culture Luke Cage when you
don't get fed the ball though you know
what seems like you you're not
initiating
am I gonna play these need to be fed I
like to play defense because defense is
a start of everything if you play good
defense you will be rewarded that's how
it just sound like your normal pickup
player Chris well well well Mike I got a
wreck game tonight
listen I block a shot you feed me the
ball I got like eight fifteen if you got
like an hour to kill tonight a half-hour
to stretch oh yeah the stretch is very
important early I'll pick you up all
right hold on a minute you're playing
hoops during the fourth quarter of
tonight's game well it's the last game
of the season rich we win tonight we're
number one in the league so what does
that get you know we could get away one
of those giant trophies I mean the big
ones that everybody gets those those
yeah one of those huge big ones one of
the big big the big the big okay great
would it be if you showed up with the
man who plays I'm not gonna lie we don't
have any height on our team because we
play the same guy these guys are playing
I don't blame this guy before I started
playing Luke Cage so you know you know
it's just normal with those guys but
then it wasn't why they bring in new
guys that come in and nobody tells them
that I'm playing basketball with them
yes and I could see the look on their
faces when I come on the court in their
Lane mm-hmm and they're like you know
sort of like I go yeah it's me how you
doing you know yeah maybe we could play
basketball so do you think LeBron at the
end of Game one was in fact in position
for the charge or do you think he was no
look I'm not messing on this he was
moving he was moving that his feet were
not set and this has started a long time
ago this whole thing about the charge I
understand he read the play well but his
feet were not set he was sliding
underneath them and so for me unless
your feet are planted before that guy
actually leaves the ground that to me is
not a charge I mean it's it's a real
time it's very hard to call that but I
felt he was sliding in that that's how I
felt I thought it was lying well I mean
we're looking at it right now yeah so
okay so play it back now we'll play it
back the wrist you're saying his right
foot was sliding he was like yeah it was
it was so quick on this one see yeah
right right there right foot still still
movie he's trying to get in position but
you can't then and also and say let's
review it to see if he's outside the
surface obvious is that could be also
notice he sort of he sort of
turned a little to the left it's like
he's kind of like leaning it and the
brother what you have to work Durant's
coming at you know LeBron weighs the red
buff 3040 pounds I mean he could take
that straight up III I thought if he
stood his ground and sort of sold a
little bit he sort of look like he was
it's it's minuscule one guy says is it
offensive one guy says it's you know so
my word okay I'll take a brain I didn't
change the game anyway you think that
doesn't momentum you think that was it
let's take a Mike Colter at real Mike
Colter on Twitter he plays Luke Cage as
you know on Netflix we're back with my
culture in 60 seconds all right welcome
back to the Rich Eisen show another
segment with Luke Cage himself Mike
Colter otherwise known as hot takes with
Mike Colter here on the Rich Eisen show
so you don't think that the there's 30
seconds to go instead of the Cavs having
the ball up - and Durant gets two free
throws instead you don't think that's
that changed the game or you're just
saying that jr. Smith pulled such a rock
that it didn't even listen the happiest
man about that is uh is he'll he'll miss
a free throw man I'm gonna be honest
let's let's be honest let's should not
have been up to you know jr. the free
throw was missed and then he passes back
to Hill Hill got blocked now Hills happy
listen jr. is gonna be the guy the goat
not the kind of goal we like but this is
the situation but no the free throw
should have been hit and let's be honest
in 30 seconds anything could happen
Golden State they could scored 20 points
in 30 seconds they could have but you
know even if the Cavs have an empty trip
they take 20 seconds off the shot clock
then not only foul immediately and input
he'll or somebody like him on the line
again you got to hit those free throws
man it's tough it's tight it's tight so
that was our poll question on Friday
what was the biggest game-changing
moment to change from the charge to the
block or junior Smith you to chosen
junior Smith I you mean as a big
game-changing moment of game number one
I just honest that it's a free throw
it's the free throw I wasn't even an
option it is it is the only option it's
the free throw you can't omit the free
throw now you have to score something
right in 4.5 seconds so what's the
acting equivalent of what JR Smith did
showing up for the biggest scene without
knowing your lines and
was live is live stage aya nee-chan
going up going up on your line to the
point where you can't even you can't
can't pull it back you can't if there's
a there's a time there was a guy an
actor I know will say his name but I
love this guy he we got into a run and
we were doing week after week after week
and that point camp comes on he's
supposed to enter and he got very lazy
and he's to always come just about the
right time he had to travel from like
backstage and look at two minute trip
well he forgot his Q and Q came up and
intercom and he wasn't there he wasn't
even there and he hadn't even started
his trip yet and so there's about a good
minute of just there's no nothing you
can do we don't know what to say stay
disorder you know sort of like it was
like just in horror and we have a lot of
big actors and big people in the
audience and stuff and he just you could
hear running panicking trying to get on
stage waiting no luckily I was i I
didn't have to be on stage I had done I
just left and I was just sitting there
watching him and I was just like I'm
sort of like tyloo yep right okay so
there you go so wait a minute so ty
Lewis also he might as well be right
Lakers play across the street he's too
far away
oh yeah well I thought no I thought my
mom was trying to call one but he was a
[ __ ] was he not sure look in real-time
also though at least whoever this actor
was yeah you know named
I'm not gonna say his name do we know
that we know who this actor is though
you do do but there's more than one
reason like I say his name it's it's it
goes until I can't I can't say his name
there's nothing to do with like or what
does it rhyme oh [ __ ] rhyme with what is
it run
no no but at least you said that there
was a two-minute space yes actor who the
hell's gonna think junior Smith is
dribbling the ball out and realizing
what the hell he's doing that's that's
that's that's true but but I was
wondering okay he didn't take the shot
immediately whatever time I thought if
you get the rebound I thought okay you
missed the free-throw don't you have a
plan for what happens if you hit the
free-throw if you don't isn't that like
a coaching thing I'm not saying that
they should have or did not I just
thought that as soon as you if you're
lucky enough to get the rebound over
Kevin Durant we have a plan we have a
plan I thought that this was something
that a detail where you go miniscule we
have sex
what are we gonna do if this happens
what are we gonna do if this happens and
what are we gonna do god forbid this
happens and I thought that Dave got
caught a little bit there if it was
assumption made mike colter here on the
Rich Eisen show dropping some news in
the last segment that Todd Bowles has a
cameo in season 2 of Luke Cage we're you
Luke Cage tries to I'm looking for a
game and I do believe we have an
exclusive soundbite of Todd Bowles yes
responding to Luke Cage okay here we go
[Laughter]
that was in response to being asked how
Sam Bradford looked on day one Oh
practice and he was just making fun
because you know he could raise his
voice actually taught balls you know
what that's that's the that's the that's
the Bill Belichick approach works for
him so now who else has got cameos that
we'd know I'm so well it's you know what
we had a well we did they didn't have
him up there but um you know Michael
Jamel they they they're all Michael
Smith yep
Jamel Hill oh is it true that Stephen a
he's understood yeah he was on the
trailer we have to even a in there yet a
lot of hip-hop say no more third season
you're in there buddy listen we didn't
know you were interested we didn't know
I was on ESPN before all those people
you telling me dude you listen i i i
would say grow up grew up but it wasn't
good I wasn't growing up I was in
college watching you and Stu create the
platform in which everybody else is
standing on right now I'm not kidding
you you guys made it cool you made it
him I didn't watch anything I didn't
watch friends I don't even know what
friends was until like I got out of
college I'm not kidding you I was too
busy partying having a good time I don't
know what people are doing watching
friends cuz I was like what aren't you
out having a good time
let me tell you a story about doing a
Sports Center with Stuart I did cuz he
got a lot of grief about you know his
pop culture references and they always
lost on the audience a lot uh-huh so I
once did a sport and if one of the many
sports centers do it Stuart I dropped
his Seinfeld line oh yeah and and we go
to commercial break he goes what did you
just say and I'm just told why I forget
what Seinfeld lon yeah he goes what's
that front of Mike it's from some
brothers don't watch Seinfeld
[Music]
I love Seinfeld I love curb enthusiasm I
didn't watch friends because just my
time was taken partying and I was going
to school but uh you guys I never we
never missed and you guys would play
over and over and he's my kid was in his
heyday it was a great time because we
can always watch you guys and you guys
made it really hip well uh right back at
you
that Stewart I think would have loved
Luke Cage you know you and watching you
do your thing and watching Luke Cage do
its thing and I think if he was alive to
see it he would be one of the people
crashed in the Internet to watch your
show he was I I didn't I didn't meet him
he was sitting next to me in Towe
restaurant in Manhattan Midtown and I
think I was celebrating my birthday it
was or may be my wife's birth I'm not
sure it was right he was sitting at the
booth next to him and I I was too
nervous to say anything he was with a
few people and it's too bad and I
literally I mean I think we had we were
I don't think the show had come out yet
or at least I hadn't probably I don't
think it should come out yeah I think
this is a couple when he passed it was
he passed two years ago yeah so Jessica
Jones came out so this show literally
would had just it wasn't out yet it
wasn't out yet and I remember seeing him
going oh you know that's what I'm just
not that kind of guy I wish I was and I
just would have cuz I didn't know you
know I wouldn't I wasn't thinking that
way you know but um yeah he was a great
guy yeah loved every government he'd
have been I mean he didn't turn anybody
away
seriously anybody came up to him you
know want to say anything ma'am he would
always it's too bad but it's all good
just know that he would have loved the
show no question well we had a guy that
Reggie Kathy who passed away actually in
the UM in the Indian great actor good
actor house of cards yeah yeah great
actor um play my father second season um
he had bet he had a cancer battle
himself and and I watched him from time
he got diagnosed at the time you know
from the time leaving the show and
trying to just deal with that and I kept
in touch with him trying to just check
in and stuff like that and he was so
optimistic and so brave and so wonderful
and warm and coming and said everyday
and I just thought to myself wow taught
me a lot of my life like how do you
wasn't Fortin you know what matters you
know he just was a great guy I wish I
knew him longer he just you know yeah
well in season 2 of Luke Cage you seem
to be as your character taking on your
fame uh-huh and and soaking it in yeah
okay that's part in the parcel well we
asked our poll
question today ask the poll question of
the man who inspired it through his
portrayal of Luke Cage Chris yeah Mike
would you rather be a superhero in
disguise or a superhero in the open ooh
well on the show in the open works great
in real life if I had powers I'd want to
be in disguise because as we know there
are repercussions for every good deed
done nowadays I need to do some good
deeds and not have to worry about people
you know kicking me out of the country
for doing them it's unbelievable how so
many people want to be in this guy yeah
guys you know listen all the bad people
are in disguise
I mean you did nobody shows their faces
everybody's like you know into it
nobody you here's the thing you doing
something good you should want to be in
the open right that's how I look at it
but when you're doing something bad you
know you might want to put something
over your head you look forward to Luke
Cage season 2 coming out really
appreciate you coming on here Thank You
Man
you got it and congratulations as I said
so in season 3 that's when I get scene 3
dude I'm gonna call my Creator right now
say listen we got to figure this out
we're gonna do this we're gonna do it
let's do it absolutely if you need any
help coming up with a role for me I'll
help as well myself I've I've got what
else have I done
announcer I've been announcer you've
been Scott you actually that's true you
played yes well Stuart and I were in
what was it Disney's the kid together
okay okay these did our cameos and when
it came time to filling out the
paperwork well we wanted to be credited
yeah Stuart's like how about you put
down me and I put down you yeah so it's
just hard Scott as Rich Eisen and Rich
Eisen it's Stuart so you swap well we
did that me my creator toying with the
idea getting Luke Cage out to LA because
I live in LA and I'll have to place
there too but I don't mind shooting here
so return with the idea so first stop
Luke Cage comes out in Los Angeles will
be the Rich Eisen show that'll be great
we are here for that and then next will
be shown up at Brockman's
basketball game to 8:15 tonight over
there you go across the street from the
Fox fantastic make sure you get your
knees stretch Nicolay's real Mike Colter
on
Twitter hey don't you strained your
hopefully this first and many times you
hanging out here hope so man you got my
Coulter here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience